musica incredibile
e lo studio non è abbastanza Largo per
tenere la spada che si tiene da sola
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video di Favij fa video
strani come sapete tutti a me piace Star
Wars ho fatto video anche in passato a
riguardo
io hanno spedito Appunto questa spada
laser ancora da boxare descatoliamo
questo incredibile spada laser e poi la
utilizzeremo ma vi spiego dopo come la
utilizzeremo prima descatoliamo
sperando che si aprisse ma mi sa che
devo fare questo anche Darth Vader
quando si scaricava la sua avrà avuto Sì
ma com'è tenuto cioè questa cosa secondo
me è una vera ma veramente una bella
Madonna no però senti prego senti senti
un attimo
Ok allora abbiamo il tubo a neon da
questa inquadratura è veramente una cosa
terrificante quello che sto vedendo
fai ancora video di Happy Wheels
c'è il mio ego che sta impazzendo Cioè è
fantastica sta roba Io direi di
sfruttare la spada come facciamo
[Musica]
Che cosa devo fare nella mia vita guarda
Oh Ma cosa cazzo sta roba eh tipo 250
una roba del genere ok cioè oh oh oh
[Musica]
Grazie Ciao ragazzi Che la forza sia con
me
però è la battaglia di Dark Souls col
cavallo
Ma dalla scuola ho combatté tutto il
giorno che
mucca latte
ragazzi
Ehi lui è bravo
guarda c'è gente daglielo
[Musica]
questo costume comunque puzza eh
se non ti lavi Ma [ __ ]
Comunque se posso dire se posso dire è
un costume tutto di punta tranne ci sono
ci sono c'ho le rebook Non so se si è
mai visto un Darth Vader con le Reebok
però
delle rebook siano con me cioè è un po'
strano effettivamente sono nere Vabbè fa
contrasto fa niente
sta succedendo